with the release of Jonathan Alan's and
Amy Parnes shattered inside Hillary
Clinton's doomed campaign the patina of
credibility surrounding Hillary
Clinton's presidential campaign has
finally imploded we know that her
campaign was plagued by infighting
stupidity and arrogance we know that all
of this mention couldn't unify Democrats
during the primaries and she couldn't
unified Democrats even after the
primaries we know that you didn't take
the most rudimentary polling data in
swing state four weeks before the
election we know she had no centralizing
message to her campaign yet today
Democrats worked on Hillary's campaign
were concerned with demonstrating that
everybody on the campaign got along
famously famously do you hear
never mind that Hillary lost the most
winnable election in history against
Donald Trump Donald Trump know
everything was hunky-dory
so like moths to the Twitter flame
Hillary staffers emerged to show the
mutual love from the campaign trail yep
look at these all these happy people if
Hillary they love each other
ah look at this oh it's so nice
everybody's so happy while she's losing
to Donald Trump yeah see people
sometimes melted each other like they
like each other and everything that an
awesome time while losing to Donald
Trump you guys because we know pictures
always demonstrate that people love each
other and are not engaged in
dysfunctional relationships that end in
disaster
right like Stalin and all those people
uh no Jay and Nicole and the Menendez
brothers and Yoko knowing the Beatles
and Bill and Hillary Clinton well oh
well so much for that I'm Ben Shapiro
this is the Ben Shapiro show
[Music]
they got nothing gang I mean Hillary's
campaign was a complete disaster it was
a complete cluster F and in the reason
that was because the person who top
didn't know what she was doing but we
will get to all of that plus I want to
get to Bill O'Reilly being ousted from
Fox News what does that mean they're a
bunch of lessons to be learned from that
particular one plus a little bit later
in the program we're going to be having
on base
stick man basic minutes Kyle Chapman who
became famous because he whacked
somebody with a stick during a march
2017 rally for Donald Trump in which an
Tifa attacked and he defended so we'll
be talking with him in just a little
while about the goings on the latest
goings on at Berkeley and Ann Coulter
and everything else but first I want to
say thank you to our sponsors over at my
Patriot supply so if you are concerned
about the fact that the North Koreans
are actually interested in nuclear cuts
and seem rather unpredictable and keep
testing missiles and are obviously
building up their thermonuclear capacity
if this concerns you at all and you are
worried about the possibility of that or
natural disaster basically anything
going wrong where you're in need of food
but you haven't gone to the grocery
store or there's a rush on the grocery
stores and the government can't get to
you that's why you need to go over to
prepare with been calm prepare with been
calm eight eight eight eight oh three 14
13 for your four-week emergency food
supply it's only $99 plus free shipping
it lasts for four weeks obviously and
that means that you and your family are
going to be safe for four weeks for just
99 bucks meth and low enough price that
you do once you stick it in your
basement and then you don't have to
worry about it until disaster strikes at
which point you're glad that you spent
299 dollars with my Patriots apply at
prepare with Ben comprehend calm 888 803
1413 out here in California everybody is
worried about earthquakes but nobody's
actually go on and done their shopping
well if you go to prepare with Ben comm
eight eight eight 803 1413 you don't
have to worry about it you just stick
that in the closet
and then next time disaster strikes
you're the only one on the block who is
prepared and safe prepare with Ben calm
$99 four-week emergency food supply and
I've been told that staff that it tastes
like home cooking so it tastes pretty
good apparently all right prepare with
Ben comm check it out okay so big story
of the day remains the ouster of Bill
O'Reilly at Fox News so the biggest host
in the history of Fox News is now out on
his on his rear and that is in a May
amazing thing I mean it's obviously a
sort of earth-shattering move when it
comes to the women when it comes to the
media and there's a reason why this
happened and that is that all of these
women were coming forward and telling
stories about how Bill O'Reilly was
hitting on them there they were all
coming forward and saying that Bill
O'Reilly had had you know tried to
solicit them for sex and then when they
had not given in then he had refused to
help them with their careers that
basically held out the carrot of I'll
help you with your career if you have
sex with me and then he had backed off
of that the minute they wouldn't or he
had called them up on the phone and said
dirty things to them all of this is bad
stuff and he had settled out apparently
many many times and Fox News had settled
out many many times they did an internal
review of ala varieties you know
supposed to escapades and they had Paul
Weitz which is a major law firm to the
internal review and apparently there was
a split in the Murdoch family Rupert
wanted to keep Bill O'Reilly and the
sons wanted to get rid of Bill O'Reilly
because they thought that he was a
liability now a lot of advertisers had
dropped out and this I think is the
first thing to say the first thing to
say is that there is a real tendency on
the right to run from people because
they've lost their advertisers and the
left knows this and that's why Media
Matters has been used for years as the
tip of the spear in fighting the
right-wing media when we weren't
truthful we tried to apply the same
tactics to MSNBC we were actually
successful we wanted to establish a
mutually assured destruction here is my
view
advertisers should generally not be
boycotted based on the the shows upon
which they advertise I think secondary
boycotts are generally not a good thing
I think they create a less free culture
in America it's not a legal thing but it
is a a culture thing if the idea is you
don't like Bill O'Reilly and so you're
going to boycott his advertisers then
you are effectively cracking down on a
certain amount of free speech nothing
you can't do illegally not that it's not
in some cases moral to do it but as a
general rule this kind of ease with
which we do this now or we call up
advertisers and say we're going to
boycott your company unless you call
advertising from a particular show this
is how the left really slammed rush
limbaugh after the sandra fluke incident
this is how the left is going after
people like Michael Savage the left has
also gone after obviously now Bill
O'Reilly so Media Matters basically
astroturf
500 or a thousand people to call up
the advertisers on Fox News and say we
don't want to see your probe we don't
want to see your commercial on Bill
O'Reilly or we're going to pull all the
money they've done this to Glenn Beck as
well basically if you're anybody on the
right and you've reached a certain level
of notoriety the left will at some point
attempt to go after your advertisers
which is really nasty stuff and
advertisers should know going forward
that this stuff happens there is that
there is astroturfed attempts to destroy
particular hosts because the left wants
to destroy the hosts not because the
advertisers are really in any danger
usually a 500 people sort of in the
advertising industry they don't want
controversy and they are not interested
in having 500 people call their
headquarters and so the easiest thing to
do is you pull your ad and put it
someplace else or you can get an equal
number of eyeballs but it would be great
to see advertisers actually a little bit
deeper digging and see whether it's
Media Matters creating a listserv that
they send out to 100,000 people and then
500 of them call or whether it's
actually 500 potential clients of the
advertiser who have decided they're
really really angry but there's really
widespread outrage over all of this now
that's it so that's point number one is
that just because boycotting on a reilly
work doesn't mean that boycotting in
general is a good tactic or worthwhile
tactic or a useful tactic particularly
the mainstream commentators of either
side I think that's sort of a problem
the second point here is the O'Reilly
specific points that one's not specific
to O'Reilly because this happens as I
say to a lot of conservative hosts from
time to time in their career which is
why for example you will see and the
right doesn't engage in this right will
will not boycott advertisers because
they advertise on Chris Hayes or or
Rachel Maddow the left will boycott
advertisers or at least say they're
going to boycott advertisers based on
you know stuff that the advertise based
on them advertising on Sean Hannity show
for example and that's why when you
watch Fox News a lot of the advertisers
are gold companies or walk-in shower
companies and you and watch MSNBC it's
all institutional advertisers meaning
you know car companies you know beer
companies because the even though MSNBC
has way lower ratings than Fox News and
the reason for that is obvious and
that's because these advertisers are
wary of being slammed with bad publicity
now boycotts work on both sides and in
some cases I think boycotts are
justified like I think that you're
perfectly within your rights to say I
don't feel like going to target if I'm
afraid that I'm gonna bring my
miles into a bathroom and then a man is
going to walk into the bathroom in the
girls bathroom I think that's perfectly
legit it's a perfectly responsible
action I don't think it's legit when you
say I don't like the point of view on
this particular show therefore I'm
boycotting the advertiser on this
particular show that's directed at the
at the exercise of free speech again
legal I don't think it's particularly
moral I'm not a big fan of it so that's
point number one point number two is the
the O'Reilly specific part and this is a
real problem for the right so they're a
bunch of women who have now come out
made allegations that Bill O'Reilly
Margaret Hoover was one of the women who
used to be on Fox News a fair bit and
yesterday she was talking about never
being alone in a room with Bill O'Reilly
Bill O'Reilly never hit on me Bill
O'Reilly never sexually harassed me I
will say though as a young woman
many of us have experiences at our own
comfort place and I have some
experiences were uncomfortable enough
for me to know never to put myself in a
position where I was alone with Bill or
alone with people that made me feel
uncomfortable and so when I heard first
read Gretchen's complaint and when
gretchen carlson complained who was
really the hero and the unsung hero of
all of this story book she is the one
woman who stood up in the face of a
culture that was condoning bad behavior
for years and years and years and years
they were definitely believable because
there was just a feel of interacting at
times that was deeply uncomfortable and
it was easy for me to extrapolate that
if I hadn't been doing these to protect
myself that I might have ended up in a
position where I could have been
followed okay so there's a point to make
sure that I think is kind of amusing in
one sense she says that she makes a
point never to be alone in room with a
man and the entire left goes yeah that
makes perfect sense because men are pigs
Mike Penn says he makes a point never to
be alone in a room with a woman and the
entire left goes insane I mean his
assumption is that men are pigs so my
pens make the exact same assumption as
Margaret Hoover and Margaret Hoover is
right and Mike Pence is wrong but the
broader point that she's making is that
there was a culture at Fox News too
tolerated this sort of stuff Kirsten
power says the same thing here's what
she said I was on air actually with
Margaret Hoover who is at CNN now on a
regular segment we were on every Mondays
and he got Margaret's name wrong and
Margaret said hey get my name right and
he said oh I'm sorry there's a lot of
blondes in this operation I can't keep
you all straight Megyn Kelly's coming up
starts telling all these blonds names
and then at the end of the segment says
thank you for your blondness to both of
us so I went to his executive producer
and I said he needs to apologize and he
needs to never do that again
or I'm not doing a show anymore and I
was told basically well you know bill
there's nothing we can do about it he's
a throwback he's kind of an Archie
Bunker and I said well if you mean he's
a Neanderthal then we're on the same
page he can never do that again I'm a
political analyst here when to bill came
back said no he's not going to apologize
so then I went to my I was called into
my boss's office I was told what can we
do it's still there's nothing we can do
you know we're sorry this happened to
you but there's nothing we can do I
complained to Roger Ailes I was told the
same exact thing there's nothing we can
do it's bill he's a jerk nobody likes
him yeah and then Roger said you know
bill he likes to put up dirty pictures
and ask pretty girls to talk about them
okay so the the idea that you know
O'Reilly would have to apologize for the
fact that Fox News has lots of blondes
on there and you made a comment about it
I think that's a bit of a stretch I mean
let's be real about this Fox News has
lots of blogs I mean I think there is
definitely a blonde affirmative action
program that exists at Fox News and you
know making it making a comment about
that is not even close to the bad stuff
that Bill O'Reilly is accused of doing
and there's an entire list of bad things
that Bill O'Reilly has been accused of
doing this ones is not even chart but
here's the problem there was indeed a
culture at Fox News that basically was
tolerant of what appears to be a lot of
allegations of sexual harassment not
just about O'Reilly but also about Roger
Ailes of course Roger Ailes was said to
have said really dirty things and
threatened people's jobs based on their
refusal to have sex with him all of that
is deeply troubling stuff and as far as
the O'Reilly allegations I always find
it hard to believe that none of the
allegations are true when you have like
10 allegations there's a bunch of
allegations about the about this whole
that's all shtick yeah there's people
who Andrew Makris is one of his
producers who I knew when when she
actually has to had me on a Reilly show
a while ago
she was she she wanted me at ten million
dollar settlement from O'Reilly that was
the famous case where he was calling her
up in the middle of the night allegedly
and then he was suggesting that there
as a that there was a that she's a
little fun all this kind of stuff you
know that that sort of stuff to many
allegations to simply dismiss although
I'll give you a quick list every man
receives that nine million dollar
settlement after O'Reilly allegedly made
sexual references to her via phone form
against Wendy Walsh accused O'Reilly of
offering to help her at Fox but cutting
her dead when she refused to sexual
advances former guest Julian
received one point six million dollar
settlement from Fox News after she
alleged that he made sexual phone calls
to her and then tried to harm her career
former host andrea tantaros filed the
lawsuit against o'reilly and roger ailes
who was absent last year after similar
allegations laura do similarly sued both
both over similar allegations received a
settlement in excess of a million bucks
former host rebecca gomez diamond the
alleged sexual phone calls from o'reilly
and then there's a report this week from
attorney Lisa bloom that one of her
clients is called hot chocolate by
O'Reilly and then O'Reilly leered at her
there's some people who write this kind
of stuff off I don't somebody who works
in an office and runs in office I don't
think it's appropriate for people to be
acting in this manner I think just as a
gentleman forget about the office
environment just a gentleman it's not
appropriate to be acting in this manner
and there was a tolerance of this sort
of behavior obviously up to and
including Roger Ailes and by Roger Ailes
also and that's a big problem now the
reason that I point this out is not to
suggest that all males are pigs and all
males are sexual harassers and that
there's a rape culture in the United
States what it is to suggest is that
powerful people are able to get away on
both sides of the aisle with behavior
that would have the rest of us in
serious trouble and that's a problem and
that's not just because powerful people
are able to manipulate the system that's
also because we as citizens look up to
powerful people people we see on TV a
lot people who are in politics and we
are willing to excuse their sins based
on the fact that we like all the other
things that they are saying and doing so
Wendy Walsh was one of the people who
sued O'Reilly or alleged that activity
by O'Reilly
she is spoke out yesterday and she
talked about O'Reilly and Trump and
remember Trump defended O'Reilly over
all of these allegations originally
um do you would you like to see the
president the United States addressed do
you think he was a it was appropriate
for him to do it in the first place
yeah I mean doesn't have better things
to do we got a problem with Korea right
now in Syria I mean come on
but I do think these two are birds of a
feather they're men of a certain
generation who thought of
as you know ornaments in workplaces and
I'm hoping I have faith in the
president's daughter Ivanka that she is
going to do more for women than her
father okay so the reason that I have a
problem with Republicans going along
with all this but Democrats always went
around the hypocrisy point Democrats
always went wrong with this right
Democrats are fine with Bill Clinton
sexually molesting the help they don't
have any problem with that whatsoever
when it's on the right side of the aisle
it's the end of the world but this is a
tendency that now crosses the aisle I
was always under the impression that
people on my side of the aisle people on
the right we're not willing to stand for
bad behavior
just because you happen to agree with
somebody it's one thing if the
allegations are not credible or it's one
allegation it gets settled out of court
for purposes of just getting it off the
table but if it's multiple allegations
you do not look askance at the people
who are alleging it if it's tons and
tons of allegations just because you
like the guy it's one thing if the
allegations are not credible but again
if you have lots of credible allegations
lots of settlements out of court the law
firm of Fox News saying this is a
problem then you do have to look at
yourself and determine whether the
reason that you are supporting a
character is because you think that they
are in the right and truly innocent or
is the reason you're supporting the
character because you agree with a lot
of the things they have to say and that
is a problem because it means the
hijacking of particular philosophies
about character about life about the
economy about everything
simply because you like a lot of what
the guy is saying we saw this with
regard to polls about Trump you know
that say that now more Republicans and
Democrats think it's okay for a
politician to cheat on his wife or have
sex outside of marriage that that's only
due to Trump and that's because there's
a follow-the-leader mentality that is
natural to human beings that we all have
to fight and the idea of having a good
ideology a good philosophy a good
religious perspective is that you follow
principle above personality I want to
talk a little bit more about that in
just a second but first I want to say
thank you to our new advertisers over at
realty shares real t-shirt so it's re al
T y re LT Y like Realty shares calm /
pen so here is what Realty shares calm
does so if you are an accredited
investor which means that you have to
make $200,000 a year you can qualify to
use Realty shares calm / bed
you can browse and signup and browse
their investments they have a whole
series of Realty investments and you can
put some of your money in
like $5,000 increments into some of
these real estate projects you can
become a real estate investor by doing
the research on these various projects
at Realty shares comm slash Ben and you
can diversify so instead of having to
sync all your money into one apartment
building instead you can take five
thousand dollars put an apartment
building in Orlando and then you can
take five thousand dollars and put it
into an apartment into an office
building in San Francisco and you can
diversify your investment this way it's
a great way to get into real estate and
it is real estate group investing so
again you're not picking up the entire
onus of the whole thing it's re alt Y
shares calm Realty shares calm you no
longer need billions or even millions or
even tens of thousand dollars to invest
in vetted real estate assets like
there's no guarantee of course that you
are going to that you're going to make
money on all this stuff real estate
investing is always risky but this gives
you the option to take a look right all
of these various projects and it's a
great way to make a lot of money if you
look at all the people who are very
wealthy that you know it's probably
because they took all the money that
they were making and they stuck it into
real into Realty and they stuck it into
real estate they're close to a hundred
thousand investors nationwide using
realty shares over sixty million dollars
in principle has been returned to the
investors it's not liquid meaning you
can't just pull your money out at first
blush you can't just decide it's not
like a stock market or something but it
does mean that you are going to start
receiving dividends on your money pretty
quickly Realty shares calm Rea lty
shares calm / Ben and you get $100
toward your first investment test
performance reports not guaranteed to
recur however historically real tshirt
shares has been a source of cash flow
investors have earned monthly and
quarterly distributions as passive
income coming straight into their bank
account it's not an offering of
securities private investments are
highly illiquid and risky are not
suitable for all investors past
performance not indicative of future
results securities offered to in
credited investors through north capital
private securities it's a member of
FINRA and the SI PC again Realty shares
comms life and fantastic way to get into
real estate investing if you are
qualified investor you get $100 toward
your first investment also use that
flash pen so they know that we sent you
as well really cool service excited to
be associated with them okay so the
reason that I lead with all the so Riley
stuff and the and the tendency the human
tendency of attempting to
follow the bat along with the good that
somebody does something bad now we're
just going to go along with them the
whole way if this involves a certain
amount of corruption of the soul and
that means corruption of the political
soul and the perfect example of this
yeah it is aside from the sexual stuff
with Trump and O'Reilly there's a
tendency because people like Donald
Trump they're going to swallow his
agenda wholesale even stuff that is
clearly heretical to basic conservative
principles so today perfect example
today Breitbart news runs a piece in
which they basically say that there is a
libertarian case for trumpian
redistribution ISM right they run it is
actually written in Breitbart news today
it's called the libertarian case for
Donald Trump's by American order John
Carney writes he says today's critics of
trade orthodoxy are so far removed from
those of the past that perhaps you
shouldn't call them protectionist at all
let's call them what they are economic
nationalists no protectionist on
protectionist he says but here's the
part that's crazy says it is altogether
possible that one may prefer lower
living standards in favor of a more
humane distribution of wealth or a
government procurement policy that
recycles dollars tax and borrowed back
into the domestic economy I'll read that
again because it's insane okay it's
altogether possible one may prefer lower
living standards in favor of a more
humane distribution of wealth now I'm
going to read that in the voice in which
it belongs you ready it is altogether
possible that one may prefer lower
government living standards in favor of
a more humane distribution of wealth
it's Bernie Sanders it's on the mark
Berman Sanders okay and they are now
parroting this stuff people on the
supposed it right are parroting the
stuff because they like Donald Trump
that is not excusable and it's not just
Breitbart news which you would expect
because Breitbart news is break our news
and they love Trump okay that's fine
it's also Tucker Carlson so Tucker
Carlson has on Mark Cuban Mark Cuban is
a billionaire and here is Tucker Carlson
with Mark Cuban in Cuban shockingly is
taking a more capitalist position is
about h-1b visas this is a program that
allows people with high-tech degrees to
come into the United States and work for
a job the reason that is good is because
otherwise these companies are simply
going to outsource the jobs or they're
going to move the company altogether
they're going to lower their labor costs
or raise their prices okay free flow of
labor is a crucial ingredient to having
lower prices and better product here is
Tucker Carlson with Mark Cuban Cuban is
right and Carlson's about to say
something that is full
on Marxism it's pretty crazy would you
apply market forces to your marriage to
your family I mean there are limits I'm
serious capitalism is not a religion
it's an effective way of generating
wealth but to the extent it hurts
Americans shouldn't we respond I mean we
don't do something dressed up like a
turkey what is it with tap water you're
going to say well that's are you against
capitalism I like capitalism but when it
hurts Americans I'm willing to make
adjustments
wouldn't you be ok that's ok when he
says would you apply market forces to
your family to your marriage market
forces what would have to do with
anything a marriage is a voluntary
agreement I make with my wife that has
nothing to do with market forces I don't
want the government intervening if I
were talking about government
intervention is it now and here's the
crazy part when he says God capitalism
is not a religion it's an effective way
of generating wealth capitalism is not
only good because it generates more
wealth and better products and services
capitalism is good because it is
virtuous ok capitalism free market is
virtuous you know why the free market is
virtuous because it says you own your
own labor you own your own money you own
the fruits of your own labor and no one
can tell you how to spend those fruits
no one can tell you with whom he can do
trade no one can tell you that you are
not able to do trade because there's
some other guys somewhere else who's
been hurt in because you're not doing
trade with him he'd be better off if you
traded with him is we're forced to trade
with him he'd be better off so we're
going to force you to trade with that
guy instead ok what Tucker Carlson says
right there is an anthem unto
conservatism when he says I like
capitalism but when it hurts Americans
I'm willing to make adjustments that is
Bernie Sanders's case it is almost
word-for-word Bernie Sanders this case
he says I like capitalism I like private
property but but whenever someone
finishes with but you know they're going
to go in a direction that has nothing to
do with capitalism or conservatism and
again that's being done because people
want to be loyal to Trump not because
it's actually good policy or anything
like that well we're going to have to go
to break right now but if you want to
see the rest of the program we're going
to talk more about this plus we're gonna
have on base stick man so you're going
to want to subscribe for that daily
wire.com $8 a month we're going to be
talking about and culture at Berkeley
you have a lot more to talk about here
on the program today daily wire.com $8 a
month gets you a subscription plus if
you subscribe annually right now then
you get jeremy borings the Arroyo a
fictional film set on our
then border about the drug cartels using
the southern border as a thoroughfare
and you can also see the rest of the
show live you can also be part of the
mailbag which we are going to be doing
on a special Friday mailbag tomorrow and
get Clayton's show live you can be part
of his mailbag so lots of goodies coming
if you're a daily wire subscriber go
over there and subscribe or if you want
to listen later in iTunes and SoundCloud
make sure you subscribe over at iTunes
make sure you hit that subscribe button
and leave us a review we always
appreciate it we are the largest
conservative podcast in the country
[Music]
you